the U.S government is really worried
about China's Ambitions when it comes to
making microchips but so far China has
not gotten its hands on a very important
machine sold by just one company in a
previous video I talked about how Taiwan
semiconductor manufacturing company
makes over 90 percent of the smallest
and most sophisticated ships in the
world their semiconductor chips power
everything from fridges to F-35 fighter
jets in other words they make
civilization function well a lot of
people who watched my video pointed out
tsmc cannot make their chips without one
piece of equipment and it's true tsmc
cannot make its chips without a 150
million dollar machine from a Dutch
company called asml asml's high-end
equipment prints the tiny features that
form the basis of tsmc's microchips
microchips are made by building up
billions of tiny transistors an asml
machine patterns the finest line lines
on the microchips using a method called
lithography the projection system
shrinks and focuses the pattern onto a
silicon wafer after the pattern is
printed it moves the wafer slightly and
makes another copy on the layer they are
built up layer by layer like layering a
cake except much more complicated
because this involves up to 100 layers
with nanometer Precision the more
transistors can be added to a chip the
more powerful the chip becomes asml is
the only company in the world that makes
a machine needed to print Advanced
microchips
it manufactures the equipment at its
factories in valdova Netherlands the
company was founded in 1984 as a joint
venture between the electronics giant
Felix and the Dutch chip machine
manufacturer ASM International
asml is now an independent company it
has a monopoly on euv lithography
extreme ultraviolet light an extremely
short wavelength of light that can
create even tinier circuitry than is
possible with conventional lithography
which relies on deep UV euv light
doesn't occur naturally on Earth only in
outer space so asml must generate it
somehow
to generate the light a CO2 laser fires
two laser pulses at a drop of tip
vaporizing it the tin vapor becomes
plasma which emits euv light this
happens at a rate of 50 000 times a
second the machines are assembled in
clean rooms containing zero dust these
rooms are 10 000 times cleaner than
outside air even the smallest Speck of
dust that ends up on a wafer can ruin it
the company's decision to switch to euv
light in the 90s gave it an astounding
Advantage it cost billions of dollars to
make the radical switch in light sources
but the effort has paid off Big Time
asml Is Now valued at around 193 billion
dollars the euv equipment is sold to the
largest chip makers in the world tsmc
Samsung and Intel every one of its
machines has over a hundred thousand
Parts they're shipped in 40 Freight
containers 20 trucks and three Boeing
747s like the rest of the world China
also relies on asml machines for Chinese
companies that are producing
semiconductor chips but in 2019 the
Trump Administration successfully
lobbied the Dutch government to block
shipments of asml's most sophisticated
machines to China in the body
Administration has shown no signs of
reversing that policy however asml is
not restricted from exporting slightly
older technology to China asml's older
deep ultraviolet systems are a
generation behind the euv ones but still
the most common way to make less
Advanced ships in 2021 16 of asml sales
went to China around 2.2 billion dollars
worth the company expects similar
figures for 2022. Washington has been
trying to hamper China's chip making
process in many ways when President
Biden signed the chips act in August it
included a caveat that if tsmc or other
chip companies want billions in U.S
subsidies for building new plants in
America they have to agree not to sell
their most advanced chips to China
Washington has also been pushing asml
even to stop shipping its less
sophisticated ship making machines to
China this could deal a serious blow to
Chinese company smic which has
reportedly been making seven nanometer
semiconductor chips that are only a
generation behind the five nanometer
ones manufactured by tsmc and Samsung
if Washington gets its way even asml's
older lithography equipment could be
banned from China
China could start producing its own
lithography systems if it wants to
become self-reliant however analysts
believe it would take China at least a
decade to build its own equipment that
could rival asmls asml CEO Peter vennink
believes it will be difficult but not
impossible he says are you not saying it
cannot be done because I know the laws
of physics are the same in China as they
are here Never Say Never they will
certainly try
sophisticated machines like a
lithography system cannot be built
without brilliant Engineers who have
mastered stem if you like to brush up on
your math science and computer science
skills brilliant is a great way to learn
interactively I use brilliant myself to
help improve my critical thinking skills
by going through their logic courses
I've noticed my viewers especially love
their computer science fundamentals
course where you can learn to program
drones in an Amazon warehouse there's
something for everyone you can solve
puzzles with science through their
scientific thinking course or practice
everyday math by seeing numbers in a new
light there are no tests on brilliant
and it's for people of all experience
levels whether you're a student or
already working if you get stuck you can
view the explanation to see where you
went wrong brilliant is free for you to
try out if you head to the custom link
in my description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people who sign up with my link will get
20 off Brilliance annual premium
subscription which could you access to
all of the offerings including the most
advanced courses thanks for watching for
newsthink I'm Cindy Palm